este año el sobregiro llega un día antes
que en 2021 lo que confirma la tendencia
de los últimos años cuáles son las
principales causas de que cada vez
consumamos más recursos
bueno como en toda crisis esta es una
crisis sistémica y las causas son
múltiples principalmente la forma en la
que nuestro sistema de producción y
consumo promovido por
básicamente la industria publicitaria y
la forma de vida que busca imitar al
norte global se ha extendido por todo el
planeta entonces el avance de la
frontera agropecuaria la combustión de
hidrocarburos para alimentar de energía
el sistema y el sistema de producción de
alimentos con los principales motores de
nuestra huella ecológica que es lo que
se mide en el día del sobregiro
si para poder revertir esta tendencia
sería suficiente hacer cambios en el
sistema productivo actual o necesitamos
dar un giro hacer un cambio completa del
paradigma productivo
en este punto de la historia los cambios
parciales ya se evidencia que no son
suficientes del día del sobregiro que
viene viviendo desde el año 1971 en el
año 1972 se publicó un informe que fue
clave para entender esta situación que
fue los límites al crecimiento un
informe que cumplió ahora 50 años y que
demostró que todas las tendencias que en
ese momento se empezaron a monitorear
que vinculaban el aumento poblacional el
aumento en el consumo de recursos el
aumento en la temperatura global el
aumento en la contaminación planetaria e
iban a llegar a un punto de no retorno
más o menos en esta época entre el año
2020 y el año
2050 es lo que llamamos la frontera del
colapso
se requieren medidas extremas y así
queremos revertir la inevitabilidad de
algunos procesos no estamos ante el pico
de todos se dice no solo el pico de
extracción de materiales sino el pico
que los ecosistemas soportan en términos
de tensión para poder asimilar nuestros
impactos con lo cual es necesario en
este punto de la historia hacer un
cambio completo paradigmático no solo en
el modelo de producción y consumo sino
en la forma en la que nos vinculamos con
el resto de la vida sobre la tierra y
entre nosotros con humanidad por que
flavia si no hacemos caso a estas
señales si no hacemos ese cambio
concreto completo perdón qué
consecuencias puede tener para los
humanos y el planeta en general como he
dicho hacer caso omiso de los síntomas
del cambio climático y del agotamiento
de los recursos de la tierra
con eso es exactamente el punto
interesante no porque estamos viendo las
consecuencias del aumento de la
temperatura global está todo el
hemisferio norte en este verano
sufriendo una ola de calor como nunca
antes en su historia algo que veremos en
los países del sur durante nuestro
próximo verano y estas consecuencias ya
están ocurriendo entonces el aumento de
la temperatura global es un indicador
más de la crisis sistémica pero es el
más visible en términos de consecuencias
y sobre todo de irreversibilidad no hay
posibilidad en este punto de acumulación
de gases de efecto invernadero en la
atmósfera de revertir algunos procesos
dentro de los cuales si el más peligroso
es el abastecimiento de alimentos porque
vamos a llegar al punto en que las
peores consecuencias de la crisis
climática van a estar ocurriendo en el
lapso de nuestras vidas y en simultáneo
no vamos a contar ni con la tecnología
ni con la disponibilidad de materiales
para
y salidas a ese problema y esa es la
paradoja del colapso estamos inmersos en
una rueda de autodestrucción para la
cual no estamos tomando medidas todo lo
contrario lo que trae el dial sobre giro
es la evidencia de que lejos de estar en
un camino de soluciones estamos
profundizando nuestros impactos
negativos por eso el día cada vez es más
cercano al primero de enero en el 71 el
día del sobregiro era el 25 de diciembre
hoy lo tenemos al día de hoy con lo cual
cada año que pasa estamos comiendo nos
el crédito en términos de recursos
naturales y capacidad de absorber
impactos que la tierra nos otorga si ese
crédito ya se está acabando ya se está
acabando también con lo cual vamos a
esperar eventos climáticos extremos
vamos a esperar olas de calor cada vez
más frecuentes pero también olas polares
porque la alteración en la dinámica
atmosférica no necesariamente va a ser
lineal y lo que a mí más me preocupa y
preocupa en este momento además de
conflictos bélicos es cómo impacta
en el sistema de abastecimiento de
alimentos